hey guys what's going on I've got an
announcement for uh 2023 so I figured
I'd just jump on uh do a quick video I'm
not exactly sure how long these videos
are allowed to be but uh we'll find out
together uh so as many of you know back
in uh 2017 exactly five years ago to the
month I started creating content on the
internet uh the general idea was put
ideas out there get feedback uh learn
meet a bunch of people uh that's exactly
what I've done I started tweeting I
think I had like 2 000 followers uh so
pretty insane to see kind of where where
we've come uh they serve right in the
newsletter doing the podcast uh
eventually on YouTube We Now reach
millions and millions of people around
the world um sure you know myself and
the team worked pretty hard but I think
we're shocked as to how big this all got
and how many people were able to reach
every single month on top of that
there's been an incredible benefit I've
been able to travel around the world
I've met extraordinary people in every
area of the world I've been able to
raise quite a bit of money
for some great causes help thousands of
people get jobs
in the industry and if I'm really honest
with myself I probably learned more in
the last five years than in the first 30
which is is pretty personally rewarding
but all those benefits didn't come
without a cost there's kind of this like
hidden secret cost that I didn't really
realize until recently and so you know
as we were building out more and more
content I wanted to do more I wanted to
do higher quality anything that I do I
try to work hard at and do it's the best
of my ability so I started to hire a
team and in order to be able to build a
team and support that team we pursued
advertising as the monetization model as
many of you know when you listen to a
podcast you watch YouTube videos there's
ads companies pay and the people who are
creating that content tell you about the
companies that are the advertisers and
that was great but this industry is a
little bit different and so one of the
issues is while we worked with some
amazing advertisers
we also worked with some companies who
did some pretty bad things and what I
realized over the last couple of months
is I was essentially renting my name and
reputation out to these businesses these
are businesses that I don't control
their businesses that don't make
decisions for the businesses that I
don't own and so in some weird way my
reputation was being used for them to
profit that's just not something I'm
comfortable with I think I came to the
conclusion that my reputation is not for
sale and so starting out 2023 I'm taking
all advertisers off the audio podcast
and off the YouTube videos so I'm
essentially blowing up the business I'm
completely destroying it taking Revenue
to zero
um every single person I've talked to
said not to do this I talked to a lot of
people who run businesses own businesses
invest in companies people have run
media companies the whole thing they all
think this is insane they tell me it
won't work I am going to be personally
funding the team at a loss for as long
as it takes and so they told me that I
was going to lose too much money they
said that you can't build content
businesses without advertisers the whole
thing I just disagree I think that this
is definitely the harder path to go by
not having advertisers on the podcast or
on YouTube videos but it is the path
that I think is the right path
um and so I'm committed to building back
uh the business in a a bigger and
stronger way without the advertisers But
ultimately I think it's the right path
because I spent a lot of time talking to
people who listen read and watch I met
some of them in person I did Zoom calls
I did phone calls I talked to them over
email in the last couple of months I've
just been trying to understand what do
they find valuable what do they not find
valuable and so you know one thank you
to all those people who who helped me
kind of think through this but two is
I'm excited to get back to why I started
all this right back in 2017 I just
wanted to learn I wanted to put ideas
out there get feedback and just
accelerate my own personal learning and
then share that with others around the
world I've been able to do that at you
know immense scale and so by not having
the advertisers I'll be able to focus
more and more on that higher quality
content it'll allow me to have the
conversations I want to have with who I
want to have when I want to have them
about what I want to have in those
conversations and so now I don't really
answer to anyone it's just you the
audience the people who watch the people
who read the people who listen uh I
think that you know if I continue to
create really high quality content and I
continue to learn I think there will be
plenty of people who will continue to
watch read and listen and so I don't
really have an ask right now
um I think you know just keep watching
keep listening keep reading uh if you
guys are doing that then I'm doing my
job and uh it's a little scary it's a
little nerve-wracking uh because uh you
know blowing up a business that you work
so hard to create but there's one thing
I learned throughout my career is that
when when something feels right you just
make the decision you do it and we'll
figure it out and in some ways
destroying things ends up allowing you
to set the Bedrock for creating
something new so I'm excited for 2023
hope all of you are as well hope you
guys are all getting off to a fast start
to the year uh we'll have plenty more
announcements we've got some things that
we've been uh been working on uh that
I'll start announcing over the next week
or so
um but I hope everyone has a great start
to the year no advertisers on the audio
podcast or on the YouTube videos and uh
let's get after it see you guys on the
internet